[Music]
the Sun radiates more energy in 15
minutes than humans use every year
around the world if only we could find a
way to channel the sun's energy more
efficiently you can make electricity
from anything light wind water and even
animal manure the most common way of
producing electricity around the world
is by burning coal in the early 1900's
Christmas lights were so ridiculously
expensive that they were often rented
instead of sold if you had lights at
Christmas it was a big status symbol a
single bolt of lightning can contain up
to three million volts that's enough
electricity to serve over 200,000 homes
also lightning can be up to five times
hotter than the surface of the Sun
electricity is lazy it will find the
quickest path to the ground did you know
that electricity can jump it can
literally leap across a distance to find
a nearest source of Earth the higher the
voltage the further it can jump this is
why I have to be super careful around
live wires and power sockets your heart
works on electricity muscle cells in the
heart are contracted by electricity that
passes through it electrocardiogram or
ECG machines also known as heart rate
monitors which are used in hospitals
work by measuring how much electricity
is going through the patient's heart
this causes the erratic movements of the
line which you see on the screen
electricity can be used to create the
world's most powerful magnets commonly
known as electromagnets Iceland was the
first-ever country to produce all of its
electricity from renewable sources go
Iceland electricity travels at the speed
of life that's more than 186,000 miles
per second what actually is electricity
it's a flow of charged particles
electrons and protons
around the closed-circuit electricity
cannot float of a circuit is not a
complete loop thanks for watching
subscribe if not already I leave a
comment below let me know what you want
me to do next